[Music]
welcome to how the light gets in
online festival and to the mystery of
reality
at the heart of our understanding of
reality is physics the cornerstone of
science
but it appears to be in all sorts of
trouble for decades it's been predicted
that we would find
supersymmetry a set of parallel
particles for all we currently
understand
to exist it was supposed to be the
solution
to many inconsistencies and deep puzzles
of our current
theory ten thousand scientists
collaborated to build a large hadron
collider
to find the evidence but year has
followed yera no evidence
of the predicted supersymmetric
particles has been found
so is supersymmetry dead and with its
string theory
the theory of everything and the life's
work of many leading particle physicists
is our underlying theory of everything
the standard model
fundamentally mistaken must we conclude
that the whole framework of contemporary
physics might be wrong
and if so where can we turn for an
alternative
to help us debate this question we have
john ellis
hi how are you doing john ellis is the
maxwell prize-winning physicist whose
research among
other things is concentrated on
discovering supersymmetric particles and
is the last man alive
who understands how cern actually works
jim baggett a science writer who pens
books for a general audience
about various aspects of physics and has
been i think it's fair to say
jim an outspoken in opposition of what
you call fairy tale physics is that fair
and sabine hossenfelder is a theoretical
physicist
working on quantum gravity and
modifications of general relativity
and also documents her ideas on the
popular and rather feisty blog back
reaction hello salina
hi is supersymmetry dead
john do you want to do you want to kick
off for us
okay well i'm i'm happy to try
uh so perhaps i better say right from
the beginning that i'm not a sort of a
supersymmetry ultra my research
interests have always focused on
phenomenological aspects i wouldn't say
just a particle physics but also
astrophysics and cosmology and
uh so i'm kind of a sort of an
op opportunistic uh scientific primate
who will pick up whatever tool is lying
around
in the hope of uh being able to use it
to crack
what the debate title is called the
mystery of reality
so so let me just sort of situate where
we are
currently with with particle physics
because the question was raised whether
the standard model is mistaken or not
it's not mistaken but the standard model
works perfectly fine
the issue is rather that the standard
model leaves open a whole bunch of
extremely important questions
uh let me just mention one just to get
started that is
dark matter so the astrophysicists the
cosmologists
tell us that there must be some
additional stuff out there
which gravitates but we don't know what
else if anything it does
and i think it behooves us physicists to
try to solve that mystery
which concerns you know far more
matter than the actual visible matters
described by the standard model
so the standard model is not mistaken it
has open questions
and for me that doesn't mean to say that
physics is in trouble it means that
there's a fantastic
opportunity uh i would also take
issue a little bit with you saying that
the lhc was constructed to find
supersymmetry
it was constructed to do many things one
of course being
to find the higgs boson which it did and
it continues to look for super symmetry
now to come to the s word
i actually checked my publications so
15 of my publications have the word
supersymmetry or supersymmetric
in the title and you know it reflects
the fact that supersymmetry is one of
the tools
that i like to use to crack the mystery
reality but it's not the only one
so so why do i think that supersymmetry
might be an
interesting tool it's not particularly
because it's beautiful
i think that uh something which works
well
is beautiful i was interested i think
principally my interest was triggered by
the possibility
that supersymmetry could provide the
dark matter
i was also interested in the way that
supersymmetry could help us
construct grand unified theories and i'm
also interested because supersymmetry
enables us
with certain assumptions to calculate
correctly
the mass of the higgs boson my interest
has always been
in practical aspects of supersymmetry
and that's actually one reason that's
why i don't
pay so much attention these days to
strings
back in the 1980s i worked a bit on
string theory and string model building
but i basically
gave up on that because it seemed to be
very difficult to make contact with
reality
so anyway there you are i'm interested
in theories
that can help us understand the mystery
of reality
thanks john jim
right so um my perspective on this whole
debate
um is is really just a question of
uh very simplest very simply honesty and
integrity
particularly at a time like this we're
here having a virtual festival because
of a pandemic that swept across
europe and the us and is now sweeping
across south america
where the messages from our governments
about following the science
are fundamentally important for us as
citizens to decide
what it is we do and how we behave
and for this to work effectively we've
got to have some level of trust
in scientists now physics is
the hardest of the hard sciences
um and and yet and and i'm not
pointing any accusing fingers at john in
in this particular situation
but the very framing of this debate as
david has just given it tells us that
something fundamental has gone wrong
because the standard model is not super
string theory and supersymmetry the
standard model is a set of
so-called quantum field theories which
work perfectly well
but as john says are full of explanatory
holes now
that's unsatisfying because we'd like
answers to some of the questions that we
have about dark matter and
higgs mass and other things but as a
result
of the hype surrounding super symmetry
and string theory for something like the
last
30 or 40 years there's now a great
confusion i think
amongst the general public of the status
of these theories
these theories aren't actually theories
their ideas
their ideas that have been put forward
by theoretical physicists that are no
doubt extremely well founded
but their ideas and somehow as a result
of
endless streams of popular science books
and documentaries
and articles published in the popular
press we have this general idea
that these these are the the theories
that explain the nature of our reality
they do not
so if you think of super symmetry like a
car we we test drove this car at the
large electron positron collider years
ago
we test drove this car at fermilab in
chicago in the us we test drove this car
around a 26 kilometer circuit called the
large hadron collider and every time the
car broke down
now we have a glossy brochure that tells
us what supersymmetry will do for us
and you've got to make it now make a
choice this car has broken down
many many times do you still believe
what the glossy brochure about this car
tells you
or do you decide in fact that that's
actually not a car all you've got is the
glossy brochure
thanks jim sabina
yeah so i i think i would like to
directly answer your question is super
symmetry dad
um the answer is no it you could say
it's undead
uh you can't kill it uh and that's
that's a problem
um so it it helps to look a little bit
at the history
that uh jim already outlines a little
bit uh super symmetry
um goes back to an entirely mathematical
idea
or actually i should say ideas because
it was simultaneously discovered by
several people
sometime in the 70s and it was then
recognized as john already said that it
would make
a potential explanation for dark matter
and it would aid
the unification of the interactions and
and that i think excited a lot of
particle physicists
however super symmetry ran into conflict
with experiment already um
in the 1990s very early and it then had
to be
fixed by adding another assumption on
top of it so that
it would still be viable and then it was
expected to show up at the chavitron and
at lab
and then ultimately at the lhc and that
was just not the case and um
so i don't think that's particularly
convincing uh for a theory
um the other problem with supersymmetry
is that
you said in the introduction that it
solves inconsistencies it does not
it is an entirely superfluous idea it
does not actually solve any problem
the only reason that um a lot of
particle physicists like it
is that as i keep saying it's pretty
they were hoping it would solve certain
problems but in the end it turned out
um it did not and john
rather confusingly said that it helps
you to calculate the higgs mass
this is just not the case you can't
calculate the higgs mass with or without
supersymmetry okay
thank you very much so if if i've
understood you basically
we we have a rather elegant even
beautiful idea i'm
hesitating to say theory because of what
jim said but certainly an idea and
it's beautiful when it springs out of
the mathematics so that i suppose the
question is
if supersymmetry was correct um
john wouldn't we have actually found
convincing physical evidence by now or
do you think we have
well i certainly don't think we found
evidence for supercemetery so uh yes i
found
one point of agreement with the other
participants in the debate
to get pretty much disagree with pretty
much everything else
so to continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas